for our daily cancellation to day we
begin with a viral video that's been
getting a lot of positive attention
especially on the right conservatives
seem to find it quite encouraging they
see it as a sign perhaps of good things
ahead for the culture as we enter the
year 2024 my take as you might expect is
not quite that optimistic uh I'll
explain but first let's watch the video
here it
is guys I went on a date this week and I
felt the feminism leaving my body I live
on the east side of LA and if you don't
know what that means it's sort of like
the artser part of La you know it's it's
people say it's like Brooklyn and New
York like so I go on dates with a lot of
men and women who you know live over
here there's always a negotiation about
who pays and that's great I like to pay
for people all that but what I will
say is that I sort of fell into going on
a date with the most gu guy I've ever
been on a date with and he's from West
West you know Santa Monica he's a bro
right a GU guy is usually not my type
like I can not remember the last time
that I went on a date with like a
straight Bros bro you know what I'm
saying but it befell me it befell me in
an organic fashion so I'm on this date
with this guy and the thing about a
guy's guy is he's putting his card down
he's paying for everything and I really
just it sort of activated something
feral in me I'm not going to lie we went
to like another bar and he went he was
going to go to the bathroom so I was
getting prepared to pay for our drinks
cuz he's been paying all night of course
I'm going to pay for the next round but
as he's going to leave for the bathroom
he turns to me and he hands me his
credit card and he goes here's my card
get us
whatever it might be time for me to get
away from all these you know liberal
snowflakes on the east
side okay now as
difficult as this can be for me I'm not
going to get hung up on Mya here the
phrase it befell me in an organic
fashion is
not really English and doesn't make any
grammatical sense and if I was single
and someone uttered that sentence on a
date in my presence I would leave and
never call again and I also wouldn't pay
but that's not the point now as I
mentioned conservatives are generally
celebrating this video because it
supposedly shows how in this individual
case traditional masculinity vanquished
feminism she even says that the feminism
is leaving her body which is indeed the
kind of thing we love to hear but but
but on the other hand if I must be the
guy who always finds the Dark Cloud
inside the Silver Lining it's hard not
to notice
that right now she only appear appears
to be excited about the fact that the
guy paid for
everything yes she's discovered a
strange new respect for a guy's guy as
she calls him but at this point all of
that respect is based around the fact
that she didn't have to pay for her own
food or drinks if she is Awakening to
The Bleak realities of feminism so far
she is only noticed that feminism is
expensive for women and indeed it is in
just about every imaginable
way now there's nothing wrong with a
woman feeling impressed by and attracted
to a man who can foot the bill without
complaint a man who appears to be
financially stable and a good provider I
mean this is raw biological programming
women are naturally attracted to
Providers they should be it's healthy
and good if you're a woman of course you
don't want a man who financially depends
on you or asks you to go 50/50 on
everything she says at the beginning of
the video that usually there's a
negotiation about who pays and she says
that's great I like to pay for people
that's obviously nonsense she doesn't
like to pay not on behalf of a man
anyway no woman
does okay I mean it's one thing if it's
like a gift if it's a present take him
out for his birthday but generally
speaking women don't they don't like
paying for a man as a as a general
principle
on a
date and it but it's different for men I
actually do like paying whenever I'm out
with my wife I like buying her nice
things I like the feeling of providing
for my wife and kids that's a masculine
thing men feel better about themselves
when they're being masculine so uh you
know that makes sense women don't enjoy
the masculine role even if they pretend
they do that's why the ones who like to
pay will become giddy with excitement
when they meet a who relieves them of
the burden of the thing that they
allegedly enjoyed
doing
so all of that is fine and
normal but here's where the rubber meets
the
road she has discovered that she likes a
masculine man because he pays for
dinner the question is whether she will
like and accept and respect the other
aspects of
masculinity and will she be willing to
play her part and be the feminine woman
that a masculine man
desires does she want to select just
this one single solitary aspect of
traditional gender roles the one aspect
where she gets free stuff and turn the
rest of it away because this is how it
very often goes with feminists of this
sort and it's why the the the swooning
that they do over guys guys very quickly
turns to anger and resentment because
the moment they discover that gender
roles aren't simp about getting free
cocktails Things Fall
Apart so to put the question more
bluntly for her you want a man who pays
fine
but are you also willing to drop the
feminist girl
boss and be the kind of woman that the
man who pays actually wants it's the
season of giving but you've already
given enough to your internet service
provider if you haven't been using
expressvpn when you go online and and
I'm not just talking about the enormous
internet bill you pay every month every
time you go online without expressvpn
your internet service provider can see
and log every single website you visit
and yes that includes all the sites you
visit in incognito mode in addition to
overcharging you your ISP is legally
allowed to sell all of your browsing
activity to thirdparty advertisers for
massive profits I'm done giving my
internet service provider I always go
online with expressvpn the app encrypts
and reroutes 100% of my network data
through their secure servers so my
provider can't see a thing the app
couldn't be easy to use simply fire up
expressvpn on any of your devices phone
laptop whatever tap one button to
connect and that's it unlike your
internet service provider Express VPN is
committed to your privacy their privacy
policy has even been audited by Third
parties so you can rest assured that
your data is not being logged by anyone
you've given enough to your internet
service provider this year so take back
your internet privacy today with the VPN
rated number one by tech radar and
Mashable visit expressvpn.com Walsh and
get three extra months of expressvpn for
free that's EXP R SS vpn.com Walsh
expressvpn.com Walsh to learn more so
staying in the realm of meals here for a
second you can think of it this way you
like how it feels when he pays for your
dinner at a
restaurant
okay but how would it feel if you made
him dinner at home okay if the thought
of him paying for dinner makes you all
warm and fuzzy but the thought of you
preparing him a plate fills you with
feminist
rage well then the feminism really
hasn't left your body at all like in
that case you're just cheap but you're
still a
feminist now is that the case with this
particular woman I have no idea I'm not
saying it is I I I don't know I hope
it's
not um I just know that there are plenty
of feminists out there who are feminists
all the time except when the bill
comes and that really isn't a sign of
progress if anything those feminists are
the worst ones of all because they don't
even have the courage of their own
convictions but all that aside and with
these rather massive caveats established
it is true that these sorts of videos
can be an encouraging sign and it does
demonstrate a fundamental truth which is
that gender roles are not arbitrary
social constructs they are embedded
deeply in our human nature it's how we
are made modern history in the west is
nothing but the story of people trying
Des L to escape their own nature trying
to suppress and hide from the deepest
most inescapable truths of who they
are it it's the story of us looking at
how the world was worked for Millennia
how men and women have related to each
other since time immemorial and saying
no all that is wrong we know better
we'll show you guys how it's
done only to discover that we were wrong
about everything and that our ancestors
were not nearly as backward words and
stupid as we in our arrogance had
assumed there's a reason things were
done a certain way there's a reason
roles were established as they were
established there's a reason the fences
were put up it's just that we had to
tear them down to figure out the hard
way why they were there in the first
place to borrow an analogy from
Chesterton so one way or another this
video is a testament to that reality I I
just hope that this woman has the
fortitude and forsight and the
awareness the willingness to see it all
the way
through and for that reason I will not
cancel her but instead it is again the
lies of
feminism that are once again cancelled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there